[Musique]
il ne suffit pas de vouloir danser
faut-il encore savoir alors le twist est
en train de séduire toute une génération
de jeunes essaient de rejeter dans
l'aube lynch 'achat' chaleureux nous
nous sommes rendus dans un cours de
danse rue saint sulpice
je me suis madame devos l'a plusieurs
fois par semaine après leurs études ou
leur travail des jeunes viennent
apprendre à danser le garde si dense et
le gabriela pollica était la distraction
essentiel de nos grands parents
la danse de salon joue encore
aujourd'hui auprès des jeunes d'un
certain prestige que cela se comprend
aisément à l'époque des parties des
surprises-parties des boues et des super
bowl après le cha cha cha le rat pour
bien le danser il faut certes connaître
les pas il est surtout ressentir le
rythme de la danse c'est ce que le
débutant oublie trop souvent
c'est important pour vous ça va danser
oui c'est important maintenant c'est une
principale distraction et puis
c'est aussi une nécessité comment une
nécessité nécessité dans les soirées
dans la surprise party pour sortir et
une jeune fille c'est une nécessité de
savoir danser et quand on sort avec des
camarades c'est toujours mieux de savoir
danser parce que la jeune fille qui ne
sait pas danser le reste seuls noms mais
on aurait vite pas toujours andy
connaissance avec certaines personnes
quand le camp l'a pas connu auparavant
c'est à dire les jeunes filles
oui en général et pour mademoiselle
pourquoi voulez vous savoir danser parce
que ça donne deux ans et que ça permet
d'aller de partout et les amis c'est jen
ai vu que ça libère le corps
c'est un moyen d'évasion et c'est ce que
vous faites je suis agent technique mais
c'est trop gros à divertissement moyen
d'évasion la danse oui et c'est une
détente sur tout et comment évolue à la
tendance alors parce que d'abord on
prépare j'étais complètement seul et
vous cherchez à vous faire des amis mais
beaucoup parce que je ne connaissais
absolument personne enfin j'avais des
frères et soeurs mais plus âgés et
beaucoup évidemment je les avais vus
beaucoup dansé enfin jamais sans pouvoir
apprendre parce que laborieuse soit il
n'avait pas cette patience soit que par
timidité peut-être et vous êtes venu
dans un cours de danse oui là c'était
assez bizarre parce que c'est un petit
peu en passant devant la porte
j'ai vu cours de l'os et vous êtes
rentré sur
[Musique]
dites moi pourquoi avez vous désirez
apprendre à danser dans un cours de
danse aurions pu demander à des
camarades devaient apprendre la
concordance et puis c'est énormément de
mes camarades parce que ils peuvent se
croire obligé je pense qu'on apprend
mieux au cours de danse de même que
qu'avec des amis qu'avec des amis oui et
pourquoi pourquoi il y en a deux et gêné
en général on note assez gêné demandé à
des amis
est-ce que ça facilite vos relations
avec les jeunes gens de ça va danser
oui peut-être un peu nous fait
fatalement ça n'ajoute rien sinon le
facilite certainement oui
lorsque quand on invite une jeune fille
sait faire sa connaissance
de quoi les jeunes gens vous parle t'il
lorsqu'ils dansent avec vous oui
expliquez-moi compare pas parce qu'on
est trop loin quand on danse quand je
déconnais ce qu'ils ont fait et si vous
ne connaissez pas et que vous dansez le
blues ont finement non non on nage mon
adresse
ils essaient de flirter avec vous
quelques fois oui je me lucien et qu'est
ce que vous faites alors considère pas
la danse 1 1
un moyen de de flirter non et maintenant
apprenons à danser le charleston
que pensez vous d'un gène sry qu'il
savait pas danser
je les trouve assez ennuyeuse et pour
vous avez vous une jeune fille qui ne
serait pas danser vous hésiteriez oui
évidemment une jeune fille ce n'est pas
pareil que de toute façon elle sera
invitée au moins une fois au moins une
fois
oui c'est la deuxième fois qu'on ne
recommencerai pas ben non parce que je
demande c'est parti avec elle je serai
obligé de l'inviter plusieurs fois
pardon si vous êtes marié avec elle veut
obliger de l'habiter plusieurs fois
alors là
[Musique]